he is a two-time super bowl champion
head coach from back in his day
with the dallas cowboys now he is as we
all know
with the nfl on fox joining us care of
his friends at michelob ultra is jimmy
johnson how are you coach
rich i'm doing great excellent we're
we're coming the state of florida jimmy
we're coming i know you're south florida
this is tampa we're coming
we're we're coming for super bowl 55. i
can't
wait i wonder how you're sussing out
this matchup here just a couple of days
uh removed from us coming you know rich
i would have never guessed that i you
know might
even consider going up against andy reid
and patrick mahomes
but i tell you this buccaneer team you
know they're going to get
probably antonio brown back that'll help
uh
on top of that todd bowles has done such
a great job with that defense
and now with the chiefs having some
problem with offensive tackle with the
injuries of fisher
uh this is gonna be a heck of a ball
game i i
i don't know that i could pick a team it
would be a coin toss
you know as far as who's gonna win this
thing but i hope i see 38 to 36.
well you know what i'll tell you this uh
jimmy
we've never seen anybody like brady and
if there's anybody that can start the
conversation of saying well
you might see somebody similar to him by
the end of my run it would be mahomes
um i'm wondering what you do think of
tom brady and what we're seeing and and
how you can compute it
compared to all the football you've seen
in your life
in my mind there's no question about
either one of them i think tom brady is
the greatest quarterback that's ever
played because of his record
you know nobody's come close as far as
the super bowls and the playoff wins
having said that i think patrick mahomes
is the most talented quarterback i've
ever seen
maybe even more so than john elway
joel montana or terry bradshaw patrick
mahomes is i mean when we did the super
bowl last year
and studying him it's just unbelievable
the things that he can
do you know he protects the football he
makes
fantastic throws he's mobile uh he has
great
vision he can see it he throws a great
deep ball
uh he is just so extremely talented
and he's 25 years old jimmy i mean it's
kind of insane when you think about it i
mean he's in his second super bowl he
just went to his third straight afc
championship game he could go
back to back and and arrive as a
back-to-back champion quarterback a year
earlier
in his career than brady did that's
that's the whole thing about this game
is yeah
we might be talking about it decades
from now like this is when brady and
mahomes went against each other
but we could also say if mahomes comes
just oh so close to brady by the end of
his career
this is the reason why he didn't catch
him is because brady got him in super
bowl 55. it really is insane
when you uh when you just put it all out
on the table like that jimmy
you know yeah i i just don't see anybody
catching brady
including my homes uh now i talked to
brett veach about this uh here in the
offseason
you know the biggest thing is keeping
that supporting catch and i think they
did a great job
you know i know that some players you
know did some team friendly contracts
to try to stay together but it's going
to be really difficult for them to keep
that team together
with free agency uh and so you know
that's the whole key i mean i don't care
how talented that quarterback is or how
great he is
if he doesn't have the supporting cast
then he's going to struggle
um you know tom brady uh all of a sudden
he
was rejuvenated but it sure helps having
that
defense that todd bowles is put together
r with
evans uh with you know all the good
receivers that they have gronkowski
uh so you got to have the supporting
cast i don't care how good you are jimmy
johnson here
on the rich eisen show so with desean
watson having requested a trade
in houston um and houston uh introducing
their new head coach david cully today
there's obviously uh a situation to use
the phrase
that the texans need to figure out with
watson and the name that we keep hearing
over and over and over again if the
texans do
eventually give watson the exit visas
he's asking for and how
much of a hall they could get herschel
walker is the name we keep hearing over
and over and over again what would you
cancel houston
to do obviously being somebody who knows
what a franchise quarterback can do to
change things around but also knows how
one particular trade with a huge hall
can change things around as well
what would you counsel jimmy well first
of all
trades are so difficult you know with
the salary cap and
with the compensation and you know
what it's going to do contract-wise you
know as far as watson contract
but the number one thing i would do if i
was david colley
is i'd go knock on his door uh
i'd say hey deshaun let's have a
mecca lobe ultra let's talk about this
thing because we can work it out
somehow some way i mean you know i had a
similar situation
you know when i had troy aikman and i
drafted steve walsh well
that caused some tension between me and
troy but steve walsh was there just for
one reason
so i could trade him later for one two
and a three to new orleans
but until i got rid of him i mean you
know troy wasn't real happy with me i
drafted my quarterback from miami there
and so i went to troy's home i knocked
on his door
we talked about things and i set up a
tropical fish tank and we
bonded and so we worked it out so
if i was david culley i'd do whatever i
would put my ego aside and i'd say hey
deshaun let's let's work this thing out
you know we can be
great right here with the texans so just
putting it all together are you
suggesting david cully go shop for a
tropical fish tank and bring it to
deshawn watson's house
is that what you're saying jimmy
what do you mean by a tropical fish tank
did you really bring something
what do you mean by that oh yeah i know
i was into tropical fish i've always
been in the tropical fish and
troy was kind of infatuated with him one
time he
said hey i might set up a tank well it
gave me a good excuse
to go spend time with him i went one
sunday over just home in the off season
after that first year
and and after i traded walsh away
and uh we spent the entire day together
uh and we went and shopped you know and
we set up his tank and i put some
fish in there and it gave us a kind of
an excuse for a conversation from then
on
uh but it bonded us and and obviously it
was a lot more than just the tropical
fish
yes you know but but it gave us an
excuse to spend time with each other
uh and to kind of soothe out any tension
that he had
because the wall thing you know when i
had washing and eggman i couldn't play
favoritism
because that would diminish the trade
value for walsh
i couldn't come right out and say hey
troy's our guy forever and ever
you know because i wanted to trade steve
walsh and try to get as much as i could
for him
uh but it was a little bit of tension
until i worked it out
with the tropical fish isn't it amazing
uh jimmy johnson here
a few more minutes again we'll talk
michelob ultra a little bit more in a
second
uh isn't it amazing how where it's
decades later
and it's still the same stories with
quarterbacks who have their
uh potential uh job threatened
even if it's not being threatened like
you're just describing
but uh organizations have to have a
public face and maybe a private face and
aaron rodgers bringing up his future as
soon as the game's over
after a season in which he said it
really wasn't much of a thought process
it's amazing how things don't change and
that seems to be something that is
playing out in green bay
right now yeah it's it's crazy when they
drafted jordan love i thought it was a
good pick he's a very talented
quarterback for the future
you know but that's not threatening
aaron rodgers you know
he's i mean he's a hall of fame great
quarterback
and you know playing as well as any
quarterback in the league
so it wasn't you know they were
threatening him they were just looking
at the future and something for their
team i understand it
bill belichick and i talked about this i
said you know i said bill i said
we both know well in the old days you
know when you could have a game
manager and run the football and play
defense that's over with
with the real changes opening up the
passing game
if you're gonna win a championship you
have to have a franchise quarterback
and i said you know what as important as
that franchise quarterback is
you know the second most important
player on your team
is your backup quarterback because if
you don't have a quarterback you have no
shot to win in this league
and and quarterbacks are just so
valuable
i think some of them are seeing how
valuable they are now and that's why
they're saying hey i want to go to
another team
well i'm not a betting man but i'm going
to make a bet that that conversation
with belichick was on a boat
with you is that a true story is that a
safe assumption
with a gold beverage
[Laughter]
what do you what do you think uh the
cowboys should do with dak
jimmy what do you think they need to get
him signed i mean
they should have given in to the
four-year deal
uh last year would have saved them some
money
uh they wanted five years uh but they
got to get him signed and not only
is he an outstanding quarterback he's
not patrick mahomes
uh but he is an outstanding quarterback
and
you know on top of that he is a great
leader leader for that football team
uh so they need to get him signed and
the other thing is
you know until you find somebody better
you don't ever give up a quarterback
ever i mean that's just a fact jimmy i
mean you're you're not you're
and he's a special kid too and and and i
don't know
you know how much better you can get in
the nfl i mean he was
he was on pace when his leg
unfortunately snapped like that
to to lead the league in in passing both
tech quarterbacks in the state of texas
could have been one two he and watson by
the end of the year
uh but i think watson would have been
looking up at him the way that dallas
was
having to play and outscore everybody on
offense you know
yeah richie they should have signed
three years ago they should have signed
two years ago
they should have signed him you know
last all season and every time they did
not sign him
the price just kept going up but they
need to get it done
so uh let's talk about mklobe ultra they
pre-released a super bowl commercial
that asks an interesting question are
you happy because you win or do you win
because you're happy
jimmy is uh that what you're here to
talk about
it got me to thinking you know as a
coach
uh i know i was a lot better coach
you know when i was upbeat and positive
and happy
a lot better coach and uh so it really
is a cool commercial i like
it and on top of that the 95 calories
and
2.6 carbs that keeps me slim and trim
and
active and healthy
so you were a better coach when happy is
that what you're saying that's
uh somehow bad and you know what made me
happy
it is winning games not bad what's your
fav
i've got to get your favorite michael
irvin story jimmy give it to me
cough it up please you know give me your
best one
freshman year at university of miami
they
they called and they said coach uh
freshman receiver michael irving got
into a big fight
and he got into a fight with a 270 pound
260 pound offensive guard a senior
i was at home and and michael won
there in the dining hall i called
michael and said michael
what in the world are you doing i said
you know
i said first of all you're fighting a
big old offensive guard
you know out weighs you about 70 pounds
i said you know he's a senior
i said you know what what in the world
happened he's a coach
you say well he said you know i was in
line you know in the dining hall
and just because he's a senior he broke
in front of the line to me he says
listen he said i got a huge family i've
been fighting for chicken my entire life
and he said i wouldn't go let that guy
get in front of me
oh but michael's special i did he was
obviously one of my favorites of all
time uh i mean he's family to me
every time i see him he puts that big
old smile on his face we hug
each other um great great memories of
michael irvin
oh jimmy i'm sure you'll be happy to
know that his
thoughts on making sure when the buffet
is prepared this is pre-pandemic and
we're in a room
for a meeting there's all it's always a
two-plate situation for michael and he
says the same thing he's one of
a million kids and the food on his food
is his food and he'll just
i mean it's a it's the same thing it's
the same thing now that he's in his 50s
it's this it has not changed for the kid
from saint thomas aquinas
now he he has told us some stories that
you on on occasion jimmy
uh would uh would uh you know
cut somebody if they're asleep in a
meeting if they were sort of like the
53rd man on the roster but somebody with
a lot of pro bowl ability might uh
might get a nudge to be awakened on time
for the meeting jimmy did you ever do
something like that
in a heartbeat and before every
every year i'd go in in a meeting i said
listen everybody here
you're all on scale the harder you work
the more you do what i ask you to do the
more you meet the rules and regulations
and
the better player you are the higher you
are up on the scale
if you don't do those things and you're
not a good player you're and you've got
no margin of error you're at the bottom
of the scale
so i did cut one guy because he's
sleeping the backup guard been late to a
bunch of meetings
you know with troy or michael i would
have told them hey wake up
[Laughter]
confirmed by jimmy johnson
i had a scale system the head of the
company in my top sales was a little bit
late i'm gonna tell him to be on time
if a guy hadn't sold anything i'm gonna
say hey get you another job
it's like the steak knives right the
steak knives and uh and the go
and the watch for the glengarry leads
with jimmy johnson hey jimmy thanks for
the call here
love our chats whenever you uh you come
on great to hear from you i assume your
hall of fame speech is all prepared
because you know
we're waiting for your day to finally
hit and i can't wait for that pandemic
to clear for you to get your day in
canton
jimmy well i appreciate rich it will be
the shortest speech
the only thing i'm going to do is i'm
going to thank all the great players
and the great coaches that helped me get
there that's it
okay so can i can i count you in for
that because i'm the one sitting on the
set hoping for somebody's
done after 10 minutes can i can i count
you in for just a 10 minute one that's
it
you mark it down it will be very brief
okay mark it down jimmy thanks for the
call michelob ultra everybody check out
uh the
pre-release super bowl commercial that's
out right now uh jimmy johnson from the
nfl on fox and
hall of fame here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here